[Music]
[Applause]
Lucca Nate here with the outdoor boys
YouTube channel today we're in the woods
by a lake and we are going to build a
fishing cabin out of nothing but Legos
sitting next to me here is roughly 400
pounds of Legos cost me about 2400
dollars and getting it here was no easy
task
[Music]
[Music]
like yes you make a wine like this but
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so I think what I need to do is fasten
the bricks together using zip ties and I
can just put a zip tie through the
through the holes there I think we need
to go buy a bunch of zip ties
that should do it I've zip-tie to all
these pieces together let's see if this
will work it up well thanks to the zip
ties the roof is working so far took me
like 15 20 minutes just to do this one
row and I've got like 20 rows to go so
we'll see this roof is taking a lot more
time than I expect so we're gonna pack
it up call it for today
I'm gonna start working on this tomorrow
why hello it's another beautiful day and
I have been zip tying bricks together
for hours
I have 12 of these arches done I have
another 12 to go and I am down to my
last box of bricks
[Music]
once I get more than four arches up the
weight of the arches start to push the
walls out the whole thing sags and it
collapses there's putting a lot of
lateral force on the walls so the walls
are starting to bow out and that's
what's causing the failure there's a
couple solutions I could make a flying
buttress which is a small wall that's 90
degrees to your main wall that keeps it
from buckling outward but I'd have to
make a lot of them and I don't have the
bricks for that another option is I can
get some dowels or rebar and feed it
down through the wall to stiffen the
wall to keep it from bending out like
that the problem is is I can't do it on
the window and so the entire span of the
window would be too weak so a third
option is that I just scrap the roof all
together and I build the walls up extra
high and I get two sheets of plywood and
I use that for my roof instead I think
I'm gonna go with that option
the downside is I
got to undo four hours worth of zip
tying bricks I'm liking the higher roof
on this new design but we have a lot of
leftover Legos we've got a whole box
here in about 20 or 30 laying around so
what I think I'm gonna do is just give
us a little more square footage what is
that
look at that look at the size of that
guy that out he was just hiding out
inside the bricks that were we tore down
that is so cool all right guys we did it
we got the exterior finished before the
Sun set so tomorrow we're gonna work on
the interior I'm going to get the
wood-burning stove installed I'm going
to put the chimney and the roof in and
then we're gonna camp in this thing and
I cannot wait the boys are so excited
so instead of using plywood for the roof
we use styrofoam sheets half the cost
more durable easier to work with and
much much lighter
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it'll fire in the fireplace we're gonna
see if this melts the plastic yeah
that's getting pretty hot right there I
think that might melt a little bit of
styrofoam around there so we're gonna
see what happens the stovepipe is
clearing out a little space there with
the styrofoam let that styrofoam kind of
do what its gonna do and we'll see what
happens
well the break seems to be okay it's
definitely warm but it's not hot or soft
but I think the decorative chimney and
the styrofoam is not great yeah there's
the chimney smoking good okay so I know
this is gonna be bad for the chimney but
I'm not sure how bad I can feel I could
definitely feel some heat through the
bricks and most concerning bit is I can
see melted red and yellow plastic
underneath where it's melted the bricks
inside and drip down but we'll just have
to sort that out later I don't think we
should use the stove a ton there we go
guys an actual tiny fishing cabin may
out of Legos with a wood-burning stove
in it and chimney we know what we need
to do now we need to go fishing
should we start fishing the fishing
cabin right
well we need some light in here there we
go well we had some leftover brick so we
went ahead and made a Lego outhouse how
you like your Lego potty Nathan it's
pretty awesome yeah we got playing
toilet paper
oh-ho I hear somebody aha our friends
who let us build the fort here they just
brought back on the ATV so yeah get it
get it got him there you go yeah the
picture good job tom that's a nice
channel catfish there we go nice little
channel catfish okay who wants who wants
to try some spaghetti if you guys want
to see where to get the mountain house
dehydrated meals I'll put a link in the
description also put a link in the
description to where you can buy these
jumbo LEGO brick thingamajig e's hanging
out by a campfire in a cardboard box man
you're living the dream here buddy
yeah look at this buddy
yeah charm says whoa okay look at the
camera say cheese cheese congratulations
Nate let's get it back in the water okay
I got you
there he goes time to get ready for bed
guys it's real wait we're gonna say
goodnight to mommy and jacob go me
[Music]
all right I'll see you guys in the
morning
well the boys are to bed and I'm just
absolutely enjoying this fire but I've
got work in the morning so I better go
get some sleep well it's about 6:15 in
the morning and I've gotta get up I've
got work this morning
well the lego cabin did pretty well
didn't fall on us pretty proud of this
project this has been fun I'd like to
hear what you guys think so definitely
follow us on Facebook and Instagram I'll
put links in the description you leave
comments and be part of the community
there unfortunately YouTube has disabled
comments on our channel because my sons
are my videos so we can't do that right
now what am I gonna do when he grows up
and becomes too big for this well that
was fun well thanks for watching guys
don't forget to click subscribe and
follow us on our adventures every
Saturday morning we put out new videos
and I'll see you next Saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]